I'm going to talk about a threat
that most people
don't want to think about.
It's too frightening
and it doesn't seem real.
That threat is civil war.
Since 1946,
over 250 civil wars have broken out
and that number continues to increase.
There are now almost 50 percent
more civil wars than there were in 2001.
I've been studying civil wars
for over 30 years.
I've interviewed members
of Hamas in the West Bank,
ex-Sinn Féin members in Northern Ireland,
former members of the FARC in Colombia.
I've stood on top of the Golan Heights
and stared into Syria
at the top of the Syrian civil war.
I've driven across Zimbabwe
as the military was planning
its coup against Robert Mugabe.
I've been followed and interrogated
by members of Myanmar's junta.
In 2017, I was asked to serve
on a task force run by the CIA
called the Political
Instability Task Force.
One of the goals of that task force
was to come up with a model
to help the US government predict
what countries around the world
were likely to experience
ethnic conflict and civil war.
It turns out that predicting
civil war is possible.
Solid data exists on where and when
these conflicts are likely to break out.
It's just that most people
don't know that.
The task force was comprised
of two types of people,
experts on civil war like myself
and data analysts.
The experts came up
with 38 different factors
that they thought could potentially
lead a country towards civil war.
And some of those factors seemed obvious,
like whether a country was poor,
had lots of income inequality
or had a government
that heavily discriminated
against one particular group.
It turns out that only two factors
were highly predictive
and they weren't the ones
the experts expected.
The first was whether a country
was an anocracy.
Anocracy is just a fancy term
for partial democracy.
It's a government that's neither
fully democratic nor fully autocratic.
It's something in between.
So think about Hungary today.
Hungary holds elections.
Hungarians eagerly go out and vote.
It's just that whoever
wins those elections
can basically do whatever they want.
The second factor
was whether citizens in these anocracies
had formed political parties
around identity rather than ideology.
So rather than joining a party
because you were liberal or conservative,
capitalist or communist,
you joined a party
because you were Black or white,
Christian or Muslim,
Serb or Croat.
If a country had these two features,
the task force considered it
at high risk of political violence
and put it on a watchlist.
It was actually called The Watchlist
and it was sent to the White House.
So here I was,
sitting in a hotel conference room
in suburban Virginia four times a year
with a room full of really smart people.
And we talked about countries in Africa,
the Middle East, Central Asia,
but we never, ever talked
about the United States.
That's because the CIA
is legally not allowed
to monitor the United States
or its citizens.
And that's exactly the way it should be.
But I was a private citizen
and I had this information
and I could see that both of these factors
were emerging in my own country
and they were emerging
at a surprisingly fast rate.
The US's democracy has been downgraded
three times since 2016.
2016, it was downgraded
because international election monitors
had considered the 2016 election free,
but not entirely fair.
America's own intelligence
agencies had found
that the Russians had, in fact,
meddled in that election.
It was downgraded again in 2019
when the White House refused to comply
with requests by Congress for information.
And it was downgraded a final time
at the end of 2020
when President Trump refused to accept
his loss in the 2020 election,
and actively attempted
to overturn the results.
Between December of 2020 and early 2021,
the United States was officially
classified as an anocracy.
If the task force had been allowed
to monitor and study the United States,
it likely would have considered it
at high risk of political instability
and political violence
in December of 2020,
just a few weeks before
the January 6 insurrection.
And it likely would have put
the United States on the watchlist.
We also know who tends
to start civil wars.
And again, it's not the people
most of us think.
It is not the poorest people in society.
It is not the people who are most
oppressed by their government.
The people who tend to start civil wars,
especially ethnically-based civil wars,
are the groups that had once been
politically dominant but are in decline.
If you think back
to the former Yugoslavia.
Serbs had enjoyed most of the positions
in government and the military
throughout the Cold War
for decades, for decades.
But they were the ones
who stood to lose the most
as Yugoslavia democratized.
The Serbs started that war.
Iraq's Sunnis similarly enjoyed
most of the key positions
in the military and in government
under Saddam Hussein.
But when the United States
toppled Saddam Hussein,
they also threw the Sunnis
out of their positions.
It was the Sunnis who started that war.
In the United States, the rise of militias
has been driven primarily by white men
who see America's identity
changing in ways
that directly threatens their status.
They were the ones who marched
on the capital on January 6.
So why is this happening now?
It's happening now
because of demographic change.
The United States is in the midst
of a major transition
from a country whose population
is majority white
to a country whose population
will be majority non-white.
The United States will be the first
country to go through this,
but others are going to follow.
Canada is likely to be next,
followed by New Zealand and then the UK,
and eventually all the English-speaking
countries of the world.
This is likely to be especially true
if climate change causes citizens
from the global South
to increasingly move north.
These countries are going
to be looking to the United States
to see how we manage
this demographic shift.
Americans can allow
this transition to tear us apart.
Or we could use it to come together
to show the world
how to manage this change
and in the process create a truly
multiethnic, multi-religious democracy.
So how do you do this?
The first thing we have to do
is address the two big
risk factors of civil war.
Anocracy and identity politics.
To address anocracy,
we have to improve the rule of law.
We have to ensure equal access
to every citizen to the vote.
We have to reduce corruption
and we have to improve
the quality of government services.
But reforming a government takes time.
Those are not easy things to do
and it often seems impossible.
That's exactly where
the United States is today,
almost paralyzed.
This is where business can come in.
Thirty years ago,
most of us thought that South Africa
was barreling towards civil war.
Black South Africans
were increasingly protesting
the brutality of the white
apartheid regime,
and the government
responded with more brutality.
But then something happened.
The business community stepped in
and demanded real democracy.
They did this because they
had been suffering
under years of crushing economic sanctions
and eventually they had to choose
between apartheid and profits,
and they chose profits.
And when they went to the government
and said, "We will no longer support you,"
the apartheid regime
knew it could not survive
and reform happened quickly.
The business community
can also help address identity politics
by investing in those communities
that have been left behind
by globalization and by free-trade
agreements like NAFTA.
In the United States,
it was the working class
that disproportionately suffered.
Those are the communities
that are the most angry
and the most resentful today.
Businesses can invest
in better health care,
better education
and a higher minimum wage
so that they create a group of people
who are hopeful about the future
and less vulnerable to the calls
by extremists to burn the system down.
But there's perhaps an easier solution,
at least in the short term.
At least in the short term.
And that is to regulate social media,
especially the algorithms that push out
the most incendiary and divisive material.
I'm not saying that we should
censor free speech.
Let people put whatever they
want on social media,
but do not allow the algorithms
to amplify the messages
by bullies and hatemongers
and conspiracy theorists
and enemies of democracy.
If we take away their bullhorn,
their influence will decline.
I've interviewed a lot of people
who have lived through a civil war
and they all say the same thing.
"I didn't see it coming."
Berina Kovac was a young mother
living in Sarajevo at the beginning
of the Bosnian civil war.
She told me that in the months
and weeks leading up to that war,
life seemed normal.
She went to work.
She took weekend holidays
with her husband.
They went to the weddings
of their friends.
But then one night in March of 1992,
when she was at home with her newborn son,
the lights suddenly went out.
And then she said,
you started to hear machine guns.
It doesn't have to be this way.
We know an enormous amount
about why these terrible wars start.
We know that the people intent
on violence have a playbook.
We know what that playbook is.
But there's no reason why we,
the democracy-loving people of this world,
can't create our own playbook
to prevent civil war.
But to do that,
we have to be brave enough
to fight for real democracy,
strong democracy,
because only by fighting for democracy
can we ensure that we
will truly get peace.
Thank you.
(Applause)